mr. shkreli you did not provide the
committee any written testimony do you
wish to make an opening statement on the
advice of counsel I will not giving an
opening statement do you think you've
done anything wrong on the advice of
counsel I invoke my Fifth Amendment
privilege invoke my Fifth Amendment
privilege Fifth Amendment privilege
invoke my Fifth Amendment privilege
against self-incrimination and
respectfully declined to answer your
question is it pronounced shkreli yes
sir see there you can't answer some
questions that would didn't incriminate
you I just want to make sure you
understand you are welcome to answer
questions and not all of your answers
are going to subject you to
incrimination you understand that don't
you I intend to follow the advice of my
counsel not yours I just want to make
sure you're getting the right advice the
purchase of a is it whoo tang clan is
that the name of the album name of the
group on the advice of counsel I invoke
my Fifth Amendment privilege against
self-incrimination respectfully declined
to answer your questions no no you will
not
no you're not allowed to under under the
house rules you have not been sworn in
you are not recognized you are not
recognized and you will be seated
massive price increases on future
victims
it's not funny mr. Cirelli to press them
to lower the price of these drugs you
can look away if you like but I wish you
could see the faces of people no matter
what misreads
classic says who cannot get the drugs
did they need you could use that
attention to come clean to right your
wrongs and to become one of the most
effective patient advocates in the
country and I truly believe I truly
believe are you listening
yes it's your intention to decline all
answers the questions and invoke your
Fifth Amendment right yes so I asked now
that the committee excuse the witness
from the table